also die bundesregierung ist in
alarmbereitschaft wegen der steigenden
kroner infektionszahlen bei mir zu gast
ist jetzt der professor hendrik speck
virologe professor strikt wie allem
jetzt in zielen nun dass die zahlen im
herbst und winter ansteigen werden ich
glaube das ist allen klar gewesen
im moment beobachte ich es auch im
moment sehen wir eher einen langsamen
anstieg nichts desto trotz kann sich das
auch relativ schnell verändern also ich
bin angespannt aber ich bin immer noch
entspannt dabei das heißt es sollen
jetzt auch neue regeln gelten zb für
rückkehrer aus risikogebieten im ausland
da soll die eingeführte quarantäne bei
kürzer ausfallen 10 statt 14 tagen ist
das denn sinnvoll
man hat nicht die absolute sicherheit
natürlich aber da wird auch pragmatisch
gedacht und überlegt was bedeuten
eigentlich vier tage im arbeitsleben
wir wissen relativ gut aus modellierung
dass die wahrscheinlichkeit in den
letzten vier tagen das dann noch ein
jemand infektiöses potenziell aus der
quarantäne kommt sehr gering ist und
eben einen prozentsatz mit dem man auch
umgehen kann und daher ist es ein guter
ansatz das zu verkürzen oder zu
verkürzen zu wollen so weit es geht um
nicht am ende irgendwie die meisten
menschen irgendwie in isolation und
quarantäne zu haben professor strikt im
vergleich zu den anderen virologen
gelten sie ja inzwischen als relativ
entspannt wie entspannt würden sie denn
in
den herbstferien zum beispiel jetzt noch
in den urlaub fliegen ich glaube es geht
gar nicht um meinen urlaub weil ich
überhaupt nicht in urlaub machen wäre
vielleicht eingeplant haben ich glaube
auch nicht dass ich entspannt bin ich
die wortwahl finde ich da falsch weil
für mich geht es eher darum pragmatische
lösungsansätze zu finden für
verschiedene bereiche und das mag so
rüberkommen dass sich entspannt wirke
dabei aber ich gehe lieber mit dem
gedanken durch die pandemie dass das
unserem leben lang begleiten wird und
ich keine daher lösungsansätze suche für
jeden lebensbereich wie man auch trotz
der pandemie damit klarkommt im moment
ist die strategie ja darauf zu warten
was der plan a ist nämlich dass ein
impfstoff irgendwann kommt meine
gedanken wobei so ist dabei dass ich
denke okay ich gehe mit dem plan b und
möchte sehen wie wir alles andere
ermöglichen wenn vielleicht keinen
impfstoff das heißt jetzt aber auch
nochmal auf die ferien bezogen in den
urlaub fahren ja oder nein die
enkelkinder zu den großeltern bringen ja
oder nein der sozialen realität ist
momentan aber das kann man ja nicht
pauschal sagen urlaub fahren ja oder
nein da hängt es natürlich vom land ab
ob es ein risikogebiet ist welches land
ist auch ist wie gut da die gemessen
wird ob man jetzt party in new york
geplant oder ob man in den bergen
wandern geht also dass das da muss man
ja differenziert herangehen auch bei den
großeltern muss man differenziert
herangehen
ob die großeltern jetzt ein besonderes
risiko haben sich zu infizieren oder ob
die
aber oder ob die kinder jetzt aus einem
gebiet kommen wo sehr viele infizierte
gewesen sind also daher kann ich das
auch nicht pauschal sagen aber generell
den kontakt von kindern zum großeltern
sehe ich nicht als den schlimmsten
kontakt an wo jetzt die großen
übertragungen stattfinden können das
heißt noch mal zusammengefasst worauf
kommt das ihrer meinung nach jetzt an in
dieser herbst und winterzeit für mich
ist es wichtig dass wir da
lösungsansätze finden für alle
lebensbereiche und dass wir auch
verstärkt darauf achten wie dass wir
nicht nur die infektionen im blickfeld
nehmen sondern auch stationäre
intensivmedizinische behandlung weil
wenn es dort knapp wird dann ist es
wirklich kritisch in der pandemie im
moment haben wir keine richtwerte in dem
sinne wie sich das deutschlandweit
verhalten soll ich gehe nämlich schon
davon aus dass die meisten großstädte
auf an die grenzwerte 35 50 auf 100000
kommen werden und daher denke ich
wichtig dass wir auch nicht nur die
infektionszahlen aber zusätzlich die
anderen daten die wir ja sammeln auch
mit ins blickfeld nehmen die nicht
vernachlässigen sie fordern ein wenig
mehr in die normalität zurückzukehren
trotz corona mit krone wie realistisch
ist es denn in ihren augen das ist bei
tests für zu hause gibt jens spahn hat
er ja was in aussicht gestellt hat aber
jetzt keine konkreten termine genannt
ja also ein bestandteil um in einer
achtsamen normalität zu kommen also ich
glaube nicht dass eine ganz normale
normalität möglich ist aber in eine
achtsame normalität zu kommen ihr sind
die anti gen tests auch die schnelltests
ob es jetzt ein hallen gebrauch gegeben
wird also was man zu hause machen kann
das steht in meinen augen noch ein
bisschen in weiterer ferne ball
da sind die richtlinie und die vorgaben
auch vom gesetzgeber sehr viel höher
dass man das einfach sogar einfach mal
auch für den heimgebrauch rausgeht woran
liegt das angst hat dass die falsch
angeredet werden
ja das hingeben davon ab wo abgestrichen
werden muss dass es auch richtig
angewendet wird
da das sind so viele verschiedene
bestandteile da drin wo sich zum
beispiel auch ein mensch daran verletzen
kann wo man wenn man das dann wirklich
aus dem medizinischen fachpersonal
weggeben geben will in den hausgebrauch
professor strikt vielen dank dass ihr
heute bei uns im studio ein dankeschön